Der absolute Hammer: Es sind nur noch wenige
Tage: Am 2.
März wird sich die “Crew Dragon”-Raumkapsel
von SpaceX auf den Weg zur ISS machen.
Die Besatzung: eine Puppe.
Die NASA hat SpaceX die Genehmigung erteilt
und plant schon für Juli den ersten bemannten
Raumflug vom Boden der USA seit dem letzten
Flug des Space Shuttles Atlantis am 8.
Juli 2011.
Der Währenddessen wird Elon Musk, Chef des
Weltraum-Unternehmens SpaceX, in Sachen Mars-Besiedlung
immer konkreter.
Clixoom Science & Fiction - abonniert den
Kanal, denn hier gibt es täglich spannenden
Science-Videos - herzlich willkommen!
Elon Musks Pläne zur Besiedlung des Mars
nehmen immer weiter Gestalt an.
Schon im kommenden Frühjahr also wenigen
Wochen soll ein Prototyp von “The Starship”,
die Big Fucking Rocket Inzwischen genannt
wird, getestet werden.
Und nicht nur das: Musk hat die Preise für
die Mars-Tickets verkündet und die sind sogar
in einem Bereich, wo Millionen Menschen sich
ein Ticket leisten können.
Elon Musk wurde für seine Ideen damals bei
der Gründung von SpaceX noch belächelt.
Mittlerweile ist seine Firma ein anerkannter
Dienstleister in Sachen Weltraum-Transport-Business.
Vielleicht werden wir das eines Tages ja auch
einmal rückblickend über seine Visionen
in Sachen Mars-Besiedlung sagen.
Hier rückte Musk vor kurzem bei Twitter mit
der Sprache raus: “Very dependent on volume,
but I’m confident moving to Mars (return
ticket is free) will one day cost less than
$500k & maybe even below $100k.
Low enough that most people in advanced economies
could sell their home on Earth & move to Mars
if they want.”
Musk ist also optimistisch, dass die “meisten
Menschen in entwickelten Volkswirtschaften”
eines Tages in der Lage sein werden, sich
einen Flug zum Mars zu leisten.
Je nachdem, wie die Entwicklung der Raumflüge
vorangehe, könne man mit einem Preis von
500.000 US-Dollar für Hin- und Rückflug
rechnen.
Umgerechnet sind das etwa 441.000 Euro.
Eines Tages könnte der Preis sogar unter
100.000 US-Dollar, also auf etwa 88.000 Euro
fallen.
Wir haben ja hier bei Clixoom Science & Fiction
schon oft über die Pläne von Elon Musk und
seiner Firma SpaceX berichtet.
Derzeit ist das Unternehmen mit dem Raumschiff
“The Starship” beschäftigt, das etwa
100 Menschen und rund 100 Tonnen Fracht zum
Mars bringen soll.
Und für Musk ist das mehr als nur Spaß:
Sein Plan, auf dem Mars eine autarke Stadt
zu errichten, ist seiner Ansicht nach die
einzige Möglichkeit, das Fortbestehen der
Menschheit zu sichern.
Und so ist SpaceX super ehrgeizig und motiviert,
alle Visionen seines Gründers wahr werden
zu lassen.
Das Hilfsmittel für die Marsbesiedlung: “The
Starship” ist knapp 55 Meter hoch und soll
auf dem Raketenträger namens “Super Heavy”
in den Weltraum fliegen.
Das Raptor-Triebwerk, das demnächst “Starship”
und “Super Heavy” antreiben soll, wurde
erst Anfang des Monats (Februar 2019) getestet.
Zwei Sekunden lang dauerte das Ganze.
Das Raptor-Triebwerk ist größer als das
Merlin-Triebwerk und liefert so den doppelten
Schub.
Anders als bei Merlin werden auch nicht Kerosin
und flüssiger Sauerstoff, sondern flüssiges
Methan und flüssiger Sauerstoff eingesetzt.
“Starship” soll von sieben Raptor-Triebwerken
ins All befördert werden; die Trägerrakete
“Super Heavy” von 31.
Die Konstruktion von “Starship” ist ganz
besonders: Anders als ursprünglich geplant
wird es nicht Carbonfaser-Mischungen gebaut,
sondern aus Edelstahl-Legierungen.
Musk zufolge soll diese Umstellung einen raschen
und kostengünstigeren Bau möglich machen.
Doch von der Atlas-Rakete wissen wir, dass
auch Stahl Probleme machen kann.
Diese war nämlich sehr schwer und brach so
auf einer Tragfläche zusammen.
Doch Musk lässt sich da nicht reinreden.
Die neue “Starship-Rakete” werde wie “flüssiges
Silber” aussehen, so Musk wörtlich.
Demnach soll die Hochglanz-Politur als eine
Art “Cool”-Faktor wirken und die entstehende
Hitze reflektieren.
Dazu schrieb er bei Twitter (am 31.1.2019):
“To be clear, I’m confident that a stainless
steel ship will be lighter than advanced aluminum
or carbon fiber, because of strength to weight
vs temperature & reduced need for heat shielding
Übersetzt also in etwa so viel wie: “Ich
bin optimistisch, dass ein solches Raumschiff
aus Edelstahl leichter sein wird als Aluminium
oder Kohlefaser.
Und zwar wegen seines Stärke-Gewicht-Verhältnisses,
der Temperaturbeständigkeit und des niedrigeren
Bedarfs an Hitzeschutz.”
Außergewöhnlich ist auch der konkrete Plan,
wie das Starship-Raumschiff vor dem Verbrennen
in der Atmosphäre von Erde und Mars geschützt
werden soll.
Musk schätzt, dass “Starship” mit 30.577
Kilometern pro Stunde durch die Mars- bzw
Erdatmosphäre eintreten könnte.
Dabei sei die Unterseite seines Raumschiffes
einer unfassbaren Temperatur von rund 1400
Grad Celsius ausgeliefert.
Und tatsächlich ist das heiß genug, um die
Stahl-Legierung zu zerstören.
Und so sieht Musk hier keineswegs tausende
Keramikfliesen, wie sie etwa von der NASA
eingesetzt werden.
Stattdessen setzt SpaceX darauf, Treibstoff
der Rakete durch winzige Löcher bluten bzw.
schwitzen zu lassen.
Dabei entsteht eine flüssige Schicht, die
zu einer Abkühlung führen würde.
Heißt also im Klartext: Der Raketenkörper
würde sich bei der Landung selbst abkühlen
- und zwar mit Flüssigbrennstoff.
Musk stellt sich eine Art Edelstahl-Hitzeschild
vor, das somit nicht nur für Abkühlung sorgt,
sondern zudem auch noch die Stahlkarosserie
stützt.
Ein Stück weit kann man diese Art von Kühlung
mit der Kühlung von Säugetier-Haut vergleichen:
der Schweiß wird aus den Poren ausgestoßen,
um eine zu hohe Körpertemperatur entgegenzuwirken.
Doch auch in der Raumfahrt ist dieses Konzept
nichts Neues.
Schon die NASA hat damit vor Jahrzehnten experimentiert.
Und hier hat sich des öfteren gezeigt, dass
es Probleme geben kann -. und zwar mit Löchern
im Hitzeschild, die blockiert und verstopft
sind sind.
Ein Ausweg könnte es beispielsweise sein,
Methan als Kühlmittel zu verwenden oder deutlich
mehr Poren anzubringen.
Unabhängige Luftfahrtexperten bezweifeln,
ob diese Ideen von Musk tatsächlich umzusetzen
sind.
Denn nicht nur der Ein- und Sinkflug, sondern
vor allem auch die Landung bedeuten eine riesige
Herausforderung - manchen Experten zufolge
ist die Landung eines Raumschiffes auf dem
Mars etwa 100 Mal schwieriger als die Mars-Landung
eines auto-großen Roboters.
Das ist alles Zukunftsmusik.
Aber das hier findet schon jetzt statt: Die
NASA hat den ersten Testflug der SpaceX Crew-Dragon-Kapsel
genehmigt.
Schon am 2.
März soll die Falcon 9 Rakete die Crew Dragon
zur Internationalen Raumstation ISS schicken
und die Kapsel soll am Tag darauf andocken.
Hier werden allerdings erst einmal keine Astronauten
mit an Bord sein, sondern nur eine lebensgroße
Puppe.
Klar ist so also: Bemannte Missionen rücken
in greifbare Nähe und zwar in sehr greifbare.
Laut dem Plan der NASA sollen noch in diesem
Jahr Menschen mit einer SpaceX-Rakete ins
All befördert werden.
Und zwar im Juli, also ziemlich exakt 50 Jahre
nach der ersten Mondlandung - mit zwei Astronauten
an Bord.
Maximal sieben Personen kann die Raumkapsel
“Crew Dragon” transportieren.
Am 8.
März soll die neue Kapsel dann wieder zur
Erde zurückkommen.
Dazu Bill Gerstenmaier von der NASA: “Wir
sind bereit für den Start, wir sind bereit
für das Andocken”.
Um 8.45 Uhr deutscher Zeit soll der Testflug
mit der Bezeichnung “Demo-1” am 2.
März, also kommenden Samstag, losgehen.
Der absolute Hammer!
Genauso wie eine Kolonie auf dem Mond.
Dafür hier klicken, anschauen und den Kanal
Raumzeit Vlog der Zukunft abonnieren!
Bis dann, bleibt dran!